Something I hear a lot from language
learners, but particularly
English language learners, is
the following statement:
'My accent is terrible' or, 'when I
speak English, I have an awful accent.'
I've been living in France for
quite a while now, and this is
something I often hear people
commenting on.
So here at English Online, we want
to tackle the subject head on.
Let me ask you a question.
Do you want to have an English,
or Scottish or American, Canadian
or Australian accent
when you speak in English?
If you answered yes, let me
ask you a second question.
Why?
If you hear one thing from
this video, hear this.
If people can understand you
when you speak in English,
your accent is not an issue. If you
become confident and fluent
when speaking in English, it really
doesn't matter what kind
of accent you have. And to illustrate
this, I want to go through
a couple of reasons why you really,
really should embrace your accent.
Reason number one: your accent
is the perfect icebreaker.
Imagine you're at a party. There's
lots of people at this party.
They're milling around, they're
chatting, and everybody has
the same accent, so the tones
and textures of voices present
in the room are all the same.
Suddenly you walk in and start speaking.
Uh, hello, I am Thomas. Can someone
please tell me where the toilet is?
Before you know it, you're surrounded
by a group of people because
they heard your accent, and they're
interested as to where you're
from. Plus, you've given them something
else to talk about other
than the weather or how it is that
they arrived at the party.
I know you're thinking that's a massive
exaggeration, and maybe it is a little bit,
but there is truth in
the fact that having a different
accent to the people around you
is an icebreaker, and it does
open up interesting conversations.
Reason number two to embrace your accent.
It shows that you are intelligent.
Do you know how many people in
English-speaking countries
speak more than one language?
36% of adults in the UK and
23% of adults in the US.
AKA, speaking a second
language is definitely not common.
It's hard work to learn a second
language, so don't downplay
the effort that you've gone through.
If you try to change and
modify your accent to resemble
an Anglophone accent, it's almost
like you're hiding all the effort
that you've gone through to
learn that second language
in the first place.
I'll be bringing you some other stats
and reasons as to why you should
embrace your accent in episode
two. So, see you then!
We are all about learning English
for the real world. Make sure
you subscribe so you know
when episode two comes out and in
the meantime, embrace your accent,
its tones, its textures,
and I will see you
next time. Bye!